hey this is presh to Walker
what is the answer to the following
problem
there's a negative sign and then 3
squared
the answer choices are 9 negative 9 plus
or minus 9 or none of the above
now you may think this is a very simple
problem that one hundred percent of
people would get the correct answer
but here's a little bit of context
I found a research paper by Peter
Glidden titled prospective elementary
teachers understanding of order of
operations
according to the abstract
78.5 percent of subjects use the
incorrect order of operations to compute
the opposite of three squared
so it's very important we go over the
order of operations
now for a little bit of more context I
did ask this question to my YouTube
Community page the poll garnered over
one hundred and ten thousand responses
and I was pleasantly surprised that the
overwhelming number of people 76 percent
did get the correct answer of negative
nine
but that does mean about 24 of people
picked incorrect choices
so let's try to see why the answer is
negative nine
we can remember the order of operations
by the acronym PEMDAS which refers to
parentheses exponents multiplication and
division and addition and subtraction
you could also remember it as bodmas or
parentheses has the analog of brackets
and exponents has the analog of orders
you have two operations of the same
precedence you want to evaluate them
from left to right so that would be
multiplication division or addition
subtraction
now in this question the only real thing
we have to do is look for the exponent
or order and calculate that first so we
have 3 squared and that gets evaluated
first to be equal to nine
so substituting that in this becomes
negative nine and that is the correct
answer
now if you wanted confirmation of this
you could input this into Google and
what I find very interesting is that
Google will show you to put the
parentheses with the three Square to
evaluate that first so this is the
opposite of 3 squared and that does give
you the answer of negative nine
you could also put it into your phone
calculator the Android phone calculator
does give you the answer that the
opposite of 3 squared is equal to
negative 9.
Now in America this is actually taught
in schools so here is a textbook called
pre-algebra and applied approach
the opposite of 3 squared is an example
and it shows you that you should
evaluate 3 times 3 first that becomes
nine and then the opposite of 3 squared
is equal to negative nine
so why is this even important so imagine
you have a function f of x equal to the
opposite of x squared
now this would be graphed as a parabola
that's pointing downward
so if you had X is equal to 3
then f of x would be the opposite of 3
squared and for sure F of 3 would be
equal to negative 9 and you would have
the point three comma negative nine so
it is important to understand that the
exponent takes place before this
opposite sign
as you learn more advanced math this
also takes place in the equation for the
standard normal bell curve 1 divided by
the square root of 2 pi e to the power
of the opposite of Z squared all over 2.
so in this case it is the opposite of Z
squared
so it is important to understand how to
solve this problem and I hope we soon
get 100 of people getting the correct
answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time